I talked to a room full of business
owners for eight hours about how to make
more money here's one of the best
moments about how to improve your offer
so there's something called in the
software called willingness to pay which
is like what's the thing that gets
people to want to buy and so they
plotted everything across this chart in
terms of the features like what are the
things in the like the offer that had
the highest willingness to pay that
people valued the most so you want to be
in this box over here and the four
things that they found were
exclusive one
access just so we have buckets to think
about this through exclusive
content exclusive
events and the way they ran This
research study they had
newsletter which to me is content but
I'm assuming that this is basically this
is probably video that was written and
so those are the four biggest things I
had willing us to pay and so they also
looked at like exclusive merch discounts
that were associated with the community
they looked at priority support like
they had a number of different things
that they looked at but the thing that
had the four that had the highest
willingness to pay were these four
things so these are the things that
people value the most within the context
of recurring Community if I were to
build a community these were the things
that I would include some of you may not
want to do this but when I um started
gym launch one of the things that we
were able to get a huge boost in
conversions was my sales guys were able
to say like you can talk to Alex every
day and so I hopped on a daily call
every single day and so they knew that
and so I would hop on Zoom for 60
Minutes same format every time I was
like hey here's how you ask a question
put the questions in the chat this is
the format if you don't follow the
format I'm not going to answer the
question rather than hearing everyone's
life story I could just be like what's
your Revenue what's your you know how
many new members a month what's the main
constraint that you're dealing with and
like what have you tried so far and so
by getting that at least in that context
I was able to just really quickly Hammer
I'd be able to answer 100 plus questions
in an hour and even if I couldn't get to
someone's question the likelihood that
their question was one of those
questions was fairly high and so what
ended up happening is like a lot of
people ended up just like eating lunch
with Alex because I did in the middle of
the day because at the time for gym
owners the middle of the day is the the
time when they have the most time like
the Peaks are morning and afternoon and
so I I would agree that if you increase
call frequency you will have more people
and it makes it very sexy from a selling
it's like you can talk to me every day
so if we're if we're looking at this
from a bucket's perspective this is one
of those uh things that we can add to
improve
any offer you have and it'll be more and
more powerful the higher the frequency
and obviously the lower the headcount
but if we're looking at very high volume
communities then it'll just be
frequencies it's the only thing that we
can really control for okay so these are
a lot of different ideas that we can do
oh go ahead we have a team that is
trained and and really fit and they
offer calls instead of you how do you
get people to want to get on a call with
your team because we have that and when
it's me everybody's coming when the team
you mean uh like group calls with the
team group calls with the team but it's
qualified coaches they have have been in
there for over a year right and they
interact with the members on a daily
basis if you can answer the questions
better than they can then it means that
they need to be better like if someone
comes to me and says hey Alex how do you
run gdn Display Network I'm like I don't
know ask I don't click anything I I
barely I don't even have my logins for
my bank account I have no
idea like you you know what I'm saying
like you're you're still very good at
that not to say you should be bad at it
but it's more like how do I get them to
be more in the day-to-day
so that they can't answer because
customers are blood hounds for value and
so like if they're going to you it's
because you're providing more value than
your team is like that's the big the big
principle you know like so I don't think
there's like a a quick hit tactic it's
like the only way they will go is either
if you just remove yourself entirely and
they're the only people they can have
access to or because I mean I I did this
I had I had my daily call and eventually
I went from five days a week to four
days a week to three days a week to two
days a week to one day a week and I
would replace them with other people now
at a certain point the the the call uh
attendance it I mean it went probably in
half but then it stayed there and
especially because the frequency they
could interact with me was much lower
like it took 12 months for me to
completely remove myself so it's not
like all right so I'm not doing daily
calls anymore coffee is with Hamed you
know like it like it it won't work yeah
it's it's very slow and then heavy on
edification and then also coaching them
on how to I mean like on Pres
presentation skills it's like literally
teaching them how to present and if have
you ever have you ever had like sales
teams with phone sales and things like
that okay well it's a lot like training
scripting and so it's like well this
person asked this question and you said
this let's play it and you do game like
this is Ops but like play it pause now
say it this way okay great say it again
great change your tone like this say it
again okay next time someone asks this
question what do you say like that kind
of drilling but that's what it takes to
to get yourself out of it and most
people aren't willing to do that which
is why most things aren't sellable so
these are access from a Content
perspective did anyone have any like uh
and like features products that were
like kind of zesty or had some you know
Zing to it that that you found people
were like this is the reason I bought
Kenneth what's the most popular part of
your offer uh the bonuses uh so like
those fast on of like things that can
fast and do something that like the
faster that they can something done the
quicker they want to get in so like I'm
fast results or fast results yeah so um
I do credit right so like helping people
clean their credit I don't do it for
them anymore but I give them my hacks to
be able to get it done fast and most of
the time it's a long process it takes
months sometimes but some of the things
that I've learned to be a get stuck from
even a day or two days so that results
to become real faster is what makes you
go buy right soon as I say that you say
the exact number of days
uh yeah so like one of my things is to
get something removed in tuning for 72
hours and once I say that you don't even
care about the rest of the stuff like
I'm get for that you know and that's one
my bonus today from a bonus uh
perspective because I literally just
finished the third book on this um
something that I've given a lot of
thought to is that people don't buy
because of the aggregate value they buy
because one thing is worth it to them
and so rather than trying to make this
list that adds up to this thing it's
more about how do I have as many very
legitimate value things that on their
own are worth an excess of the price and
so trying to think about my bonuses for
anything that way so how do I make this
just every single bonus has to earn its
weight that it has to be worth more than
the price and that'll force you to also
get a little bit more Consolidated on
the bonuses um and really just focus on
the sexiest stuff and usually for
different avatars if you have like
different psychographics of people who
are coming into your business like I'm
sure there's some people who have like
really bad credit from a long time and
some people just had like they had a
medical bill or something and something
happened right and so having specific
bonuses that are going to speak that in
and of themselves for that one Avatar is
worth it I want to have like the
punchiest most distilled every one of
these if you read it you you'd want to
buy for this alone it's like taking
mental rent it's like every one of them
has to pay rent to be there because they
only need one reason to buy I think just
asking yourself what is what is
something that if I removed everything
else if I just offered this one thing
people would still buy
and then using that as the litmus test
for every one of the bonuses that you
add and then I think it will force you
to think of better things that you can
do to make your overall offer more
valuable and I would also think about
that through the different lenses of the
avatars the guy who has a medical
emergency the guy who has 10 years the
person who got in a bad divorce like
each of them for that person this one
thing alone is worth it you valuable
like what's your experience when you
just
like he SE something
last night about them yeah I've been
running two in real life events every
month recently and um interestingly
chers actually went up which is so
surprising but it makes sense because
look I do it in real life event I bring
the boys out to like a big Park we
wrestle in the mud and then we all dress
up and go to like this business
Mastermind did you let anyone come
anyone who was inside yeah we were
thinking about now make locking it
behind a 12 month first yeah I mean that
would have been my my first thing is
like just move it so then it's like this
big thing because then it goes from I'm
missing out on this thing to I can't
wait till I get this thing and I think
like I think that that alone would
probably solve it as a second little
tidbit for anybody else who does events
whenever you do events you want to also
announce the next one upsells happen at
the point of greatest need not the not
the point of greatest satisfaction it's
a big misn number sometimes they happen
at the same time often times they don't
so like if I give you a steak dinner and
then you eat your steak dinner and then
I say hey do you want a steak you're
like no because the timing's wrong and
so we want to we want to offer them the
stick when they're starving not when
they've just eaten and so they like
after an event they've just had like
this massive feast and so they're like
I'm good for a while like I'm I got I
got my value and so it's like oh let me
open loop the fact that there's going to
be another thing that's coming and it's
even better than this thing if you think
you like this wait until dessert right
and you just you just keep pushing it
out we learned this because I my my turn
spiked at one of these massive events I
spent like two million bucks on the
event just make it this like wild crazy
thing everyone's like this was awesome
thank you so much like and I was like
what but churn going into the event went
down so it's like okay how do I get that
to stay it's like oh you just always
have one that they know that they can
come to and then I think put it past the
12 month and you'll be golden all right
so events I'm going to put two bullets
here number one is uh have next planned
and then
lock
after six to 12 oops months make it
something people earn from a value
perspective of something else to add as
a bonus like conferences events things
like that tend to have real price tags
associated with them and if you're
charging $7 you're like Well normally I
would charge $99 for this two-day
virtual event or something you get that
and again you can you can put it later
on so that they they they lean into to
staying for it as an aside and probably
an obvious point but I might as well
make it um you can also sell stuff at
those events just thr out
there fine line though is you don't want
to be spamming too much so if you have
speakers you don't let them sell at all
no no no no no no no no like no like no
one sells it your event but you and if
you're going to sell one of the things I
think I think people make a mistake of
is these people already like you you
don't need to have a very long pitch you
just need to present the offer and be
like hey by the way I've had you know
number of you guys been talking about
this stuff talk you 15 minutes if you
want do it before launch or do it before
like do it before a talking period so
that if you have sales guys or whatever
they can help sign people up having
looked at data across our portfolio
companies at run events um one really
interesting thing has come out which is
that if you can segment the audience of
the people who are attending based on
revenue and income I used to think about
like what percentage of the audience am
I converting and now I just don't care
at all it's just of qualified people in
the room who am I converting like you
can absolutely go into a room and close
80% if everyone's
qualified and so a lot of those events
from an upsell perspective are going to
be about who's in the room anyone even
do a newsletter here well people value
it that would be like posts in the
community yeah I would post and then and
then uh send email to everyone I think
an easy one is to get your successful
students and interview them it's like a
testimonial
and content and motivation I think a lot
of you guys were saying how do you get
your people motivated hearing of people
that are like them winning is the best
one of the other things that um to
talking about like what makes a company
sellable these success interviews so uh
we do this thing in our portfolio
companies called life cycle ads so
there's a lot of different ad types that
you can do that are outside of your face
and one of my favorite ones is life
cycle ads you'll see some from school
soon um but basically these success
interviews if you're smart about it you
actually walk them through an epiphany
bridge and so what that means is I'll
just draw it so you've
got
internal
external and
then before during and
after like I've looked at a zillion
testimonial templates but that's the one
that I've been able to teach and my team
can do it which is what was life like
before internally before you saw this
did this what were the external stats
that other people would observe about
you before you decide to do this
thing what made you like what made you
actually take the next step externally
and then internally what were the things
that you were most concerned about and
this is like the key question and I'll
explain why in a second but someone's
like yeah I I uh you know I I was
struggling I you you know my my wife
didn't respect me anymore cuz I couldn't
make money and then external stuff I was
making $33,000 a month I was behind on
payments I almost lost our house I had
to downgrade our car external stuff and
so then you know I saw an ad from Alex
whatever and it kind of caught my eye
and we're like well what were your
biggest concerns well I didn't know if
it was legit um well then what made you
decide to do it anyways well I saw all
the other people that had you know had
testimonials and they looked like gyms
like mine and actually found somebody on
the page that had almost the exact same
model as me and I was like okay well if
I work for that guy maybe I'll give it a
shot and this is why it's so key in the
decision-making process because you're
literally talking to the prospect from a
prospect not you walking through them
making a decision about why they laid
their fears and their concerns and took
the next step anyways and then you're on
the interview now and you say okay well
what's life like now externally and
internally well now I had I was able to
get back the car I upgraded we moved to
a better neighborhood my kids can go to
a better school and I feel better about
myself blah blah blah right and so this
is one part of the life cycle and so um
you can condense that into a 60 or 90c
ad with just the Highlight points and it
also becomes an ad and so when you're
running these interviews it's content
its bonuses and its ads let me hit a
couple uh of these I think I can
probably just round them out pretty
quickly attracting the right people
comes down to what bonuses you're
promoting and what promises go with them
and so like most times people like I
want to get richer people but when
someone poor comes on the phone I still
take their money if you want to attract
better customers you have to be able and
willing to turn away worse customers all
right I'm going to tell a three minute
story but that way you'll remember it um
I did a Consulting day years ago with a
guy who is in my space in the gym space
many years ago and he had the same sales
velocity as me so he was selling the
same number of people as I was but we
were making 70 times more profit than he
was and his cost to acire customer was
about the same as mine selling about the
same number of units but the main
difference is that his customers were
worth $5,000 and my customers were worth
$442,000 and so the thing is is that he
just ran ads about like hey if you're in
Fitness and you want to make money come
to me and my ads were you have to be a
gym owner you have to have ass signed
lease you have to have at least one
employee and you have to have at least
30 members at your gym and the way that
we figured that out was that we looked
at all of our customers found the top
20% said what do these people have in
common and then we made that the
qualification and then that ran through
every part of the funnel so that was in
the ads we said this is who it's for
this is who it's not for if you're a
trainer if you just want to make money
online if you want to do all these
things this is not for you and then R
people were like thank God I just wanted
to have like a legit place where real
gyms real businesses are here who are
dealing with employees and all that
stuff and so also to that same degree if
you have bonuses and you know that these
beginners love that bonus cross it off
because the people who are going to be
the better avatars are going to have a
very different set of things that will
be valuable for
that and so it's a it's a big strategic
change like your offer changes your
bonuses change your marketing changes
your funnel changes like you change the
business entirely when you when you
decide to attract better customers if
you are serious about it otherwise it's
just a complaint forever like for
example a really business you know busy
business owner to um to your point um
they might not want calls but they might
love the fact that they can just DM or
slack or something like that not slack
but you know like DM um to get access
and have quick responses that might be
more valuable than even having
calls and if you're dealing with
Founders then it's like Founders is very
broad but if it's like Tech Founders
then it's like okay well then that's now
we can get we can get really juicy on
this and make stuff that that they would
want like we also have our pitch deck
that has already generated over $100
million in fundraising and you can just
copy and paste your logo in and then
your benefit and selling points that
alone is worth more than the price of
this thing for 5 years so that's about
attracting the right people we covered
what to add so let's talk High ticket
versus low ticket coexisting and versus
transition so as long as the price
points aren't like too close then I
don't think you're going to have an
issue of uh
cannibalization like and the right type
of customer just wants to pay more to
have more support more implementation
help more Etc fundamentally like I like
to think of the clear line between the
two as implementation versus stuff
that's unlimited has no marginal cost
that's how I would differentiate those
things um the things that are not
immediately scalable are the things that
you charge more for so you're doing a
low ticket when do you when should you
even think about adding a higher ticket
thing you have a lot more team a lot
more employees you have more reputation
risk that goes like the amount that
people are upset for for $7 a month is
very different than $10,000 just a very
different level of upset if something
doesn't deliver um and I will hit on
this scammer thing because we might as
well hit it now the big reason the
information Market has the reputation it
does is not because of what they teach
it's because of what they promise we
have workshops here we don't do them for
free because we incur costs in order to
like put these on we have Caterers we
have all the stuff right no one's upset
because I don't promise anything I say
I'll share the stuff that has worked
well for me and if it works for you then
great
you get in trouble when you say you will
make $10,000 a month in 30 days and they
don't make $10,000 a month in 30 days
and the vast majority don't make $10,000
a month in 30 days that's like that is
fun like Dave Ramsey so like let's
zooming all the way out like the people
that you want to look at from a brand
perspective Dave Ramsey is a guru he
sells courses he sells events he sells
an app and he sells coaching literally
his four products he sells media to
technically to advertisers but those are
the four main products that he sells how
does he do it in a way that no one calls
Dave Ramsey a
scam because the promises that he makes
are absolutely justifiable if you save
$2,000 a month you will have $2,000 more
dollars a
month no one's going to fight him on
that if you didn't save the money you
didn't save the money right now that's
part of the unique thing about his
particular business is that everyone
makes some amount of money and he says
if you spend less of it you will have
more left over and if you listen to any
of his stuff he he doesn't even he
doesn't even make claims he just
provides value and then enough people
because when you're just providing value
you grow at such a faster rate that then
people just want to they just want more
and so I think someone else was early
asking questions like what is free
versus what isn't in terms of uh content
honestly the same
stuff and that's why and to be fair I
take that more as my free stuff should
be just as good as my paid stuff more
than my paid stuff is is now junk
because my free stuff is not good like I
spend a year on a book that I give away
every year and I just want that to be so
exceptional that it spreads on its own
and so I think if you think about how do
I make my amazing free stuff just as
good as my amazing paid stuff at some
point you just you draw a line and you
say if you want more of that you can pay
for it and people will be like well I
consumed all this I want more and
they'll pay for it because this was
worth more than the price of free and it
was worth more than the time they
gave go for it yeah so my question I
guess is more specific on not that it's
difficult to satisfy customers we have
no issue with that we have had not a
single complaint from people calling us
a scam sure from the program the issue
is because it's high ticket people want
to look it up people that didn't buy
that just went the sales call they're
the ones that are posting this
negativity a lot of times you just how
to tell these people are crazy but just
by the way they write but we've had a
threat yeah but we've had a threat on RD
grow for example when people search it
show thought and so it's like what do
you do to combat that let me let me zoom
out for you one every single YouTube
video that I post people are like he's
just trying to sell his course I don't
even have a course for sale so like
point one point two is that the only way
that you combat that is being 10 times
louder so think about it as like a
percentage of Mind space that exists
they're this loud if you're this loud
then they're 50% of the talking about
you so you drown it out you shrink them
into irrelevance it's the only way you
deal with it because you're not going to
change humans people who don't know you
will make an assumption because you
teach anything about making money that
you automatically have these things that
they've seen from other people who teach
money and so they will just make that
Association on their own which by the
way is what branding is so like you're
not like as long as you do this stuff
that will happen and so the question is
what do you do about it I don't think
buying the radit thread is the the
answer because another one will come up
it doesn't really matter you just need
to do this WR yeah like zero
attention like and I'm only going to
highlight this because you're here
because this is important the fact that
like you flew here and like the most
pressing question or one of the most
pressing questions you had was this is
them
winning because all of that mind space
could just go towards making more money
making the business better making the
product better like they get zero
like in general also if someone like
makes a big public blast or they do a
hit piece and I'm sure I will get one in
the future at some point I will never
acknowledge it why would I why would I
why would I tell my audience about this
thing like that's that's the biggest
gift in the world now all these people
are telling their audiences about you
and they're doing it for free okay so
that was um that was about attracting
the oh this was this one coexisting
between the two and the when uh it's
yeah it's it's an entirely different
business if you want to do that like it
will absolutely be absolutely be a
increase in in income uh the process is
is basically weaving it into the
customer Journey so if you have your
journey for the customer who comes in
they you know they get an event at month
you know whatever three and they've got
their coffee with hems every day d d
lots of coffee this is awesome we want
to make sure that the communication
that's going to them during this period
of time we want to have a
point that's an activation
point which basically demonstrates that
they're ready you don't want to pitch
everybody in the community because it
it's not for everybody and everyone
wouldn't benefit and it just won't look
good but if someone has now reached a
certain level like they hit a th000
subscribers or whatever the metric is
for you say hey guess what you won this
and then you have a call and so that
call you provide value and then you just
ask them if they want to do next
steps it's just and all you do in that
call is say you're here you want to get
here you will absolutely get there on
your own the question is whether you
want to take it 5 years or you want to
have it take 5 months yeah go ahead um
I've got a good one in terms of when you
know if you should offer a high ticket
because I think Hamel was kind of
talking about this okay yeah that's the
process
um so what I found when I was selling L
ticket first because that's how we got
started was that a lot of my successful
students
wanted more they kept coming to me and
they like how I've already hit the goal
that this course was for and I want I've
got more money but I want more I want to
go to the next level and you don't have
anything like I want more like what they
were they were like basically offering
to pay me money for something more and
once there's enough of those happening
that's when you know that there's a need
for a second level basically does that
make sense yeah need you need the demand
yeah definitely don't put it in until
there's a you can see a clear need cuz
then all you do is when you see these
people hit this Lev a lot of them will
ask for it and then you can just message
those particular people that way you're
not like smashing everyone in your
community every day about your high
ticket thing it's more just Cherry
picket and you get the best people in
with without even really promoting it
does that make sense that's what I've
found works well you can engineer the
activation Point by telling them that as
soon as they hit the objective metrics
they win an award like for us we had a
sword so when a when Jim hit a million
dollars a year they would get a sword
and so we' do the live event like when
we do the our events we'd have a award
ceremony and everyone get kned whatever
they get the sword but whatever that
that number is for you they're going to
turn in a video they're going to turn in
substantiation all of that becomes ads
by the way the second way of getting ads
from people um and then you also can
then just they will just lean into you
because they want the thing and then you
can then
Ascend but I really I will I will
reemphasize Sam's Point that like you
can you can never do it too late you
absolutely can do it too
early because like if you waited four
years and you have this massive
Community it'll just be
better like the engine's still going to
be the front end like the the community
the low ticket on the front end is still
going to be the main economic engine
that drives the demand into the higher
ticket did you guys see the guy who won
the school games this month in March
so this guy's a high ticket guy selling
Insurance stuff or whatever and he sold
a $110,000 thing that was his whole
business he came on school and then he
wanted to win the recordings from today
so by the way shout out um so and so he
just got on the phone with his normal
customers and instead of selling the 10K
thing he just uh sold them $1,000 like
$999 for a year and put him into the
school community and just got three of
them on because he wanted to get the
free recordings but then the sales were
so easy that he switched his model and
sold 50 people into that in the in like
20 something days and so um I I mean Sam
and I've talked about this at length but
I think there there is a movement that's
that's moving more from like Grass Is
Always Greener there's tons of
operational challenges that that exist
with high ticket um in general and it
also have to factoring profit cuz yeah I
know in the info space you hear a lot of
numbers throwing around was Revenue yeah
like million a month it's everyone's
goal but I've met a many people that
make million a month that actually
profit less than hamson so like CU he
has no ads and he just employs his
sibling and he lives
at and the easiest way for H to double
is just to do
Affiliates so like he could get to 400
Grand a month and I know a lot of people
that make a mill a month don't make 400
Grand a month profit for sure like 100
so always be more realistic about it
like you hear these big numbers but by
the time you pay a sales team and
ads a lot of that money's gone if I
could go back in time again we talk
about sellability of a business um gym
launch was by far the most expensive
player in the market so ours was $4,000
a month 43 technically um per month to
gym owners who on average take home
$30,000 a
year
tough there was another guy actually in
the UK and I noticed this price point
continued to reappear but there were
guys who were able to get like
36-month 40 plus month ltvs selling more
or less the same thing not the same
thing obviously but like at like $800 to
$1,200 a month and so the what I
realized from gym launch and we've you
know obviously we've since changed the
pricing and whatnot was that we had to
price to people's worst month cuz even
though if we made on average so the
average GM for us added an extra 120,000
in profit per year just using the system
that we had and so for me I was like
okay well net of us it was 120 it was
160 with us like if we didn't if we were
free right so we made a 160 net of us is
120 in extra profit now again these guys
are making 30 so I quadrupled their
income like pretty sexy offer and we did
that on
average but
they would still cancel if they had a
bad
month and so I saw that these other
people were able to maintain customers
because they had they were above their
worst month they still could afford the
thing and so because of that they knew
that if it got one thing a year it would
pay for it and they were willing to
continue to pay at that price point and
so there's a wild difference between
what someone will pay at their searing
hot pain Point versus what they will pay
after they had a stake dinner like do
you still want to have some stake well I
might want to have some stake tomorrow
so maybe I'll be willing to pay but
significantly less like that price point
compared to the value is where people
continue to pay it's just it's I was
impatient because I wanted to make the
money but if I had known like but for
context if I had 6,000 gyms right now
paying $1,000 a month I'd be making 6
million a month or that business be
doing 6 million a month just on that
side we had the supplement side too um
and so that would have also been
significantly more profitable I think if
you really do provide value you might
find that there's an amazing spot at
like $700 a month that people just like
you the thing is you'll be able to sell
like n for selling will go up like
8X right and so that's where like that
this is literally just a pricing graph
and then you just look at Max units and
LTV by the way for everybody small group
is the most profitable way to do it